please welcome to the stage the creator
of the game awards Jeff Keeley
[Music]
oh my God hello everybody how you doing
it is so great to have a live crowd with
us here in Cologne Germany for Gamescom
2022. I'm Jeff Keely and I gotta say I
am so excited to be here with you we did
this in 2019 live in person in Germany
in the past two years we had to do it
virtually from Los Angeles and in 2020
the first show that my team did together
live was that August Gamescom and we
connected with all of you virtually and
the fact that we're back here in person
I don't want to ever take this for
granted before so uh guys you ready for
a fun show
well I gotta say we have a lot of great
stuff for you tonight we have tons of
world premieres the entire industry has
come together to showcase the future for
you we've got games like Sonic Frontiers
the Callisto protocol
outlash trials Hogwarts Legacy Gotham
Knight and a lot of surprises of things
that we didn't talk about in advance so
we've got some good stuff for you
tonight here at Gamescom and I can't
wait to get started we've got two hours
of stuff so should we just get right to
it
all right
I love the Roar of a live crown and
because we got a live crowd we gotta
surprise you with some stuff tonight too
so let's start things off with our first
world premiere it's a new world from a
brand new team that has a bold Vision
let's check this out
[Music]
[Music]
we want the community to build this we
want it to be their world we want them
to tell their stories in their game I
think it's human nature to navigate on
territory to find a place where we're
free to explore to be creative and to
share amazing experiences
the goals are to make an experience
that's unlike any other which is such an
exciting thing to be part of I think
ultimately like that's kind of been the
big ambition is to create this kind of
like open world that can be built out in
every direction I think it's every day
as a new one discoveries and it's
constantly growing we've put a lot of
focus I think on the current side guys
and what it means to represent yourself
digitally this is more than a game it's
a labor of love it's a labor of passion
the dream is to create a whole new world
for the next generation of Gamers and I
think that we've we've kind of captured
that players will play a massive part in
this it's not going to be just our game
it's not going to be just what we decide
to do with it there's something in it
that will definitely appeal to you no
matter what it is that you love to do
the really thrilling aspect of all this
is that people are going to see what
we're doing for the first time I'm just
so excited for people to see what we've
been spending the last five years
pouring our hearts and souls into and
I'm excited to see how they feel about
it even though they will have to wait
just a little bit longer everywhere has
become more than just a video game for
us and today we're delighted to give you
a peek behind the curtain of what we've
been working on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there you go everywhere and I'm sure
you've got a ton of questions and
joining me now from Builder rocketboy is
Adam Whiting to hopefully answer some of
those because we're a little confused we
want to know a lot about this so tell us
uh everywhere what kind of game is this
what can you tell us Adam well firstly
can I just say it's really exciting to
just be here and we've been looking
forward to our stealth mode and really
delighted to start the conversation
today here at Gamescom
now I won't be able to reveal everything
but what I can say is that really we're
not trying to make a normal game I think
the scope and ambition of this project
are quite unlike anything else we want
to build a whole new world for gamers
and not just a place to play but watch
share create hang out with your friends
and so much more well I gotta say uh the
end of the trailer I think we all were
taken aback by whoa change art style
this seems totally different what is
that part of everywhere what can you
tell us well Jeff that's one of the many
surprises we've got in store for players
I mean we are passionate about making
games and telling stories but ultimately
we made everywhere to be a place where a
players can make their own experiences
be who they want to be and tell their
own stories but we're still passionate
about making immersive and cinematic
experiences the players can just get
lost in and enjoy I guess you say we
want people to have their cake and eat
it and everywhere is the place that can
happen all right well it definitely a
bold vision for what you're doing here
uh the other question I'm sure we're all
wondering is we didn't see a date on the
trailer any sense of when we're going to
get to play this thing where are you at
in development well I'm delighted to say
that we aim to have everywhere in the
hands of players in 2023 but we've got
many more things to show and tell over
the coming months and we're really
excited for you to sign up on our
website everywhere.game but really today
was just a sneak peek behind the curtain
to see what the team has been so hard to
work on and we're really excited to get
this in the hands of players as soon as
possible amazing well Adam thank you for
sharing the reveal here at Gamescom it's
awesome to have so many European Studios
on stage and tonight we've got a lot of
European students going to reveal their
games for the first time and right now
we're going to move to another world
premiere announcement
[Applause]
[Music]
I must not fear
foreign
killer
fear is The Little Death that brings
total obliteration
face my fear
I will permit it to pass over and
[Music]
and when it has gone past I will turn
the inner eye to see its path
where the fear is gone there will be
nothing
only I will remain
[Music]
[Applause]
trust me the fun is just beginning
tonight all right how many of you out
there are fans of PlayStation
well we've got a fun surprise for you I
said PlayStation what can we do for all
the fans come together here at Gamescom
and right now I'm honored to share this
Global PlayStation announcement with you
right here at Gamescom
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's theme song
there you go the Dual sense Edge it's a
high performance Ultra customizable
wireless PlayStation 5 controller
designed by PlayStation and you see
there you can have your own custom
control profiles customized to your play
style if you guys want to learn more
about the brand new controller you can
head to Playstation blog and thanks to
PlayStation for sharing that
announcement with us here at Gamescom
all right next up the Callisto protocol
you guys hyped for that game
thank you
well joining me now is Glenn Schofield
from Striking Distance uh Glenn we are
so excited about this game coming out in
December you came all the way over in
the middle of development to Gamescom we
really appreciate it uh how has the
response been to Callisto so far man
Jeff the response has been fantastic uh
for a new IP I couldn't ask for anything
more uh so I want to thank the fans and
uh I want to thank my team for uh just
really killing it and it's great to be
back at Gamescom man you know
well you got some good stuff for the
fans and we're going to get to that in a
second
um he brought some gameplay we saw some
great stuff at summer game Fest you
brought more now what are we going to
see today yeah you've got uh some live
gameplay uh we've got two sections the
first one is going to show some uh some
crazy combat and uh the second one is uh
something new uh from the game a little
different than what we've shown with a
uh pretty crazy ending
yes it is you guys are gonna love this
uh one thing I want to ask you about was
you're known certainly in the team for
your work on Dead Space in that game we
love the Strategic dismemberment I
understand you're kind of one-upping
things for this game well we got this
rememberment and we've shown the gore
system
um and today we're going to show a
couple new things uh including one that
we're showcasing called mutations so uh
the enemies May sometimes have these
tentacles that come out and if you don't
shoot them take them out on time this
guy in real time is going to mutate in
front of you into something bigger
better faster meaner and he's going to
be taking you out it's uh it's pretty
cool well this is one of my most
anticipated games it's coming out this
December Glenn thanks to you and the
team for putting this together let's
take a look at brand new gameplay from
the Callisto protocol
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
we got lots more covered for you but
right now I want to introduce my co-host
for Owen L Melly Melly welcome to onl
thanks Jeff I was so excited to be here
at Gamescom hello everybody I'm your
guide for tonight for all the happenings
around Gamescom and I'm really really
excited to be here because the heart of
gaming is beating once again and game
devs and Publishers from all around the
world are making their way to Cologne to
show you hundreds of new games so if you
if you're not here yet and still can
come by make sure to drop by and if you
can't make sure to me to drop by next
year because it is definitely worth a
visit and one of the highlights we have
this year is we actually have the
largest in the area ever bringing
visitors and devs closer together than
everywhere anywhere else in the world
and you can meet the makers of the most
original and fantastic and creative
games here and if you're not here and if
you can't make it here do not worry you
can also check out the Indie Arena Booth
online at gamescom.global Jeff it's back
to you thank you Molly and you'll be
with us all night we've got Gamescom
Awards to come and other things too but
let's get right back to the world
premieres this next one is one you've
been waiting for for a long time to see
let's take a look at this brand new
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right they dropped the two uh the
the Lords of the Fallen all right now
it's time for another new game
announcement the sequel to a game that
redefined the term couch Co-op check
this out
[Music]
are you struggling
missing your regular farts
have you tried going online
visit exotic destinations
move your dreams whoever you are
apply today no skills no worries
everybody's welcome you're hired
open a door of new opportunities
work alone or with a friend or two or
more
do it
move locally or connect together online
yeah
nice one
coming 2023
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
yes it's time to step into the Potter
verse you guys excited for Hogwarts
Legacy
well it is coming out in February of
2023 and tonight at Gamescom we've got
the brand new trailer for you to take a
look at I don't want to say much and
spoil much this is an incredible trailer
I hope you enjoy it
foreign
the more we know about Salazar Slytherin
and the dark arts the best prepared will
be
if either of you uses dark magic I will
notify the Headmaster immediately
unforgivable curses are so named for a
reason
spell that could save your life
shouldn't be Unforgivable
thoughts seem harmless until it's too
late
none of us will be able to avoid dark
magic forever
it's up to us I can
I give shio where I can cast it on you
I'm ready
you've made your choice
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
that's right it's time to step in the
world to Borderlands now joining me is
the founder of gearbox Entertainment
Company Randy Pitchford Randy great to
see you here thanks for the intro uh
Jeff I think a lot of these guys
probably know me from my work at gearbox
creating Borderlands any Borderlands
fans in the house
well I got good news I know uh some of
you hardcore folks saw the leak uh but
I'm here to officially announce new
Tales from the Borderlands tell us about
this we remember Tales from the
Borderlands this is new Tales of
Airlines this is new characters new
story it is you know I loved the
original game and so that's why we got
some of the original storytellers and
writers that were back in the day at
Telltale and developed an all-new
storyline with all new characters uh
created uh uh with a production from
gearbox Studio Quebec it's an all new
experience and uh we're here to show it
for the first time today you guys want
to check it out
Let's Dance coming soon too right that's
right uh coming in October of this year
October this year all platforms awesome
well let's take a look Randy this is
exciting new Tales from the Borderlands
first at Gamescom
[Music]
most stories in the Borderlands start
bloody they end bloody too
sometimes politics to change the Galaxy
is a trio of losers trying to get
through a bad day
here in the middle of a TV or Invasion
leave immediately this area is
jurisdiction they think there was a
vault key being kept on the station if
we can find whatever's in that Vault
before Titi or does we can change our
lives
like really bad
has many guns talking guns guns with
legs I'm gonna blast you so freaking fat
yeah
[Applause]
I always wanted to change the universe
for the better and now we are some tan
but more importantly we'll be drowning
people like this
[Music]
if you happen to see any corpses along
the way uh don't worry about them
they're just uh yeah don't worry about
them
come back to the city and join the
deadliest spectacle of this season
I'm gonna tell you a story about a
species that survived Millennia
Homo neanderthalensis homo rhodesiansis
Homo erectus all of them wiped out by
the deadliest species of all
us
I am Astrid this is the new Arena and my
advice for you
stay alive
every day you fight for survival but
today you fight for Glory
anyone can be a warrior What Makes You
Different is the spirit of a champion
[Music]
Red Bull gives you wind
things
so you want to join me
sign up
hold of my crew in
Portugal
product not yet rated
[Music]
when they see this glorious end
s
the last draw
foreign
[Music]
they are
because only in the end
[Music]
[Music]
hello again this Saturday the game score
Awards will be handed out to the winners
of the best games on the show floor only
submitted Games showing at Gamescom will
be eligible to be nominated and the
awards will be streamed on all Gamescom
channels so make sure to tune in but
tonight I'm allowed to hand out four
Awards I'm very very excited about that
and I would say let's jump straight into
it starting with the most Wanted PC game
here are your nonies
[Music]
metal helsinger
[Music]
System Shock
Warhammer 40 000 dark tide
[Music]
and the winner is metal held singer and
here to accept the award is Sheila
victim executive producer at The
Outsiders the stage is yours
thank you so much wow this is a lot of
people I was practicing my speech a lot
but of course you know when it's
um as much people as there is right now
you'll blank
um but I want to say that I am honored
to receive this award on behalf of my
team the team behind metal is an amazing
bunch of people that I'm so lucky to be
working with every day and the truth is
making games is super hard when I
started out I don't think I really
realize how hard and what I learned is
that focusing on compassion kindness and
empathy just as much as any other craft
in games would be the key to successful
game development and it's precisely
those qualities that my team possess and
why I'm so privileged to be working with
them every day I love you guys at home I
miss you so much so what I want to say
to you my industry friends and
colleagues is treat each other with
heart kindness and respect every day
make games with Humanity thank you so
much
congratulations once again
and death back to you thank you Molly
well the world premier train keeps going
it's time to move to the world of Sonic
any Sonic Hedgehog fans out there
Sonic has had a pretty good year with
the Sonic 2 movie which was a ton of fun
earlier this year Well Sonic Frontiers
is in development and we've got a brand
new trailer for you and confirmation of
the release date too check this out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there you go it is coming this year
Sonic frontiers all right well now
another European Studio wanted to use
Gamescom o l as a platform to announce
another narrative experience this comes
from
a French Studio check this out
[Music]
I believe so many things behind us
objects memories
mistakes
[Music]
they sink in time
touch the bottom and go to sleep
silence is full of ghosts
please
and here voices can only come from the
deep
deep under the waves
[Music]
guys
it's time for the goats ready for some
goats
no live goats today but we are here to
talk about Goat Simulator three we got
to announce this back at summer game
Fest and now it's time to see the
gameplay of Goat Simulator 3 for the
first time let's check this one out
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
November 17th that has literally about
everything you could imagine in it uh
Goat Simulator three all right A lot of
people ask me how I got started in the
industry and what I loved doing when I
was a kid with my brother we would play
PC adventure games and I grew up playing
classic LucasArts and Sierra adventure
games you guys remember Monkey Island by
chance
well I am so excited because there is a
new Monkey Island in development right
now Ron Gilbert the series Creator is
back you may have heard about it
returned to Monkey Island and tonight at
Gamescom I am so excited that we get to
announce the release dater actually I
don't we get to go to Stan to tell us
the release date check this out
[Music]
Hello friends it's your old pal stand
coming to you through the magic of
marketing to let you know that your
search for Quality entertainment is
about to bear fruit but I wouldn't be
doing my job if I just drop the details
on you without a little build up I want
you to see the kind of fine dining
establishments you'll be visiting like
this one get lost
and if escapism is your cup of flavor
you can't do much better than this
exotic and extremely remote island stay
back how did you find me
return to Monkey Island launches
September 19th which happens to be
International Talk Like a Pirate Day but
you don't have to wait you can order it
right now before it's even out something
we in the marketing industry call a
pre-order as a bonus I'm ready to unload
this shipment of beautiful horse armor
to anyone who pre-orders return to
Monkey Island it'll look fantastic in
your inventory wait you missed a spot
I've gotta go now I've got a lot of
irons and a lot of fires you know how it
is but I'll be back to steal every scene
I'm in and return to Monkey Island I'll
see you there
all pre-order customers will receive the
exclusive horse armor item in their
inventory please note that the horse
armor has no practical use in game and
in no way will contribute to the
gameplay puzzles or Narrative of return
to Monkey Island
oh my gosh a month away and I love the
horse armor does absolutely nothing it
just sits in your inventory return to my
gallery cannot wait for that all right
now let's turn to the world of unknown
Worlds the creators of subnautica as
we've teased they are here today at
Gamescom to unveil a brand new IP and
it's a departure from subnautica it's a
brand new turn-based Sci-Fi game and uh
we're gonna reveal it for the first time
right here actually special guest is
let's check this out
foreign
hi I'm Brandon Sanderson you might know
me as the author of the mistborn series
The Stormlight Archive or as the guy who
finished Robert Jordan's Wheel of Time
over the last few years I've been
working closely with my friends at
unknown worlds on the exciting project
we're revealing today
you of course know unknown worlds for
creating immersive and Fantastical
worlds like the incredible subnautica
series when they reached out to me I was
absolutely thrilled to help craft the
expansive sci-fi Universe in which their
next game is set this secret has been a
hard one to keep and we're so excited to
finally show you what we've created
together so without further Ado this is
moonbreaker
[Music]
let us keep this civilized
welcome to the party
till the end
what's up stay alive
grenades anyone
they'll never see this coming
I taste their planets
The Crowd Goes Wild
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and joining me from unknown worlds is
Charlie Cleveland Charlie moonbreaker
it's real and it's so different than
subnautica so yes it is this departure
uh you guys like to kind of reinvent
yourselves every game right yeah so
people thought we were kind of crazy for
making subnautica after making natural
selection we went from a strategy
shooter to a pacifist underwater Game
survival uh so I feel like we've done
this before we you know we love changing
genres but I'm hoping you know our
subnautica fans will still come along
for playing a digital Miniatures game I
hope it's so cool a digital Miniatures
game uh everyone loves Miniatures but
how do you translate that into gameplay
what is the gameplay of this game so uh
we're kind of channeling like uh
Guardians of the Galaxy or Firefly kind
of feel
so you can see that from the colorful
art style we have so you choose a
captain and ten crew and you build a
roster kind of like a traditional
Miniatures game and every unit in the
game is really like strange and special
and kind of game breaking so
um yeah you deploy units and you move
them around on the battlefield and you
get all these crazy game changing Powers
kind of like Hearthstone meets x-com
kinda well I I love I mean you see the
gameplay here it looks great and uh it's
coming soon as we said uh in the
September so you're not really actually
not going to wait long but the thing I
want to get to is the paint painting of
Miniatures which we saw teas of in the
trailer and I know you actually painting
was cathartic for you sort of during the
pandemic right yeah so the painting I
mean you can't have a Miniatures game
without painting and during the lockdown
I just found myself like learning to
draw and just like just zoning out and
feeling really relaxed when the world
was basically falling apart around us
and we really tried to capture that
feeling it's not like Photoshop or like
special technical tools or anything like
that you we just simulate washes dry
brushing we've got decals um this feels
like you're actually painting a real
miniature and I have to say because
everyone is surprised by it like all the
Miniatures you see painted in the game
are all painted with the tool so it's
like actually pretty powerful amazing
well it's so cool that you're revealing
it here and it's gonna it's playable at
Gamescom right it is it's here you guys
are the first ones to play it wow and uh
oh yeah it's more
we're over in the Crafton Booth okay
crafting booth and for everyone else
around the world they're not going to
wait long right yes we'll be on Steam
play test in September we have a couple
open weekends and then we're going to be
launching
um into steam Early Access September
29th so it's really close only a month
away Moon record Charlie thank you so
much for coming all the way out here
thank you I know you had a tough my
pleasure thank you everyone all right
Charlie Cleveland the known worlds thank
you so much Charlie
and now it's time to reveal another game
with a very catchy tune in the trailer
check this out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
too much
[Music]
inspired by The Familiar story of
Pinocchio lies of p is a new action
souls-like game that is coming out from
Neil Wiz and you guide Pinocchio on his
unrelenting journey to become human this
game looks absolutely great and we've
got a brand new Gameplay trailer to show
you and this game is also coming to Xbox
game pass on day one let's check it out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that you can change that
it depends on the choice you make
truth
or lie
too much of you
but I don't have a choice
foreign
[Music]
finally
we meet
son
[Music]
the stage is set
the light shines brightest in the
darkest of times
all right buddy I'm here for you don't
worry
don't give up
keep
playing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
destiny
foreign
[Applause]
yes you do you have fun
[Music]
fear of missing Gamescom
relax Gamescom is everywhere you want
games come now register now
that's right all the fun of Gamescom is
available from wherever you are online
obviously and well in case you're
wondering who that little guy is that's
EPI and he's on a mission to save the
games Converse from the evil future and
if you want to help him check out the
Epic section at gamescom.global you can
solve quests and win prizes so take part
and help Epi to save the games Converse
but first I want to tell you more about
some of the great program we have for
this week and it's quite a schedule so
please bear with me there is for example
the Gamescom Studio by IGN featuring
Game spotlights Dev interviews and all
insights into this year's Gamescom so
please make sure to check that out so
you don't miss anything and also the
awesome Indie showcases Back featuring
the newest most original crazy indie
games here on Friday afternoon at 5 30
p.m CST and I'm really looking forward
to it and some something I'm really
looking forward to to is is is the is
the cosplay contest on Sunday where the
super creative cosplay Community takes
center stage and this is absolutely one
of my favorites so make sure to not miss
it out it is definitely worth the watch
and for more updates follow at Gamescom
on all platforms and well now it is
almost time to introduce our next guest
but sadly she couldn't make it since she
is that far away so let's see she sent
us a video and I would say let's have a
look
hello Gamescom I'm Isa astronaut
Samantha christopheretti currently
flying at around 27 000 kilometers an
hour 400 kilometers above your head on
board of the International Space Station
today I come to you to say Bravo to the
games industry we see how many space
games you've been creating recently
those missions you send your players on
aren't just great fun they create
curiosity interest and the love of space
exploration in Gamers around the world
as we look towards returning to the moon
and on to Mars with an ambitious
terranova program
Humanity's space flight capabilities
will be in part thanks to the games
industry
who knows perhaps even you will be among
us here at visa for the journey
exploring space virtually isn't just
great fun it's setting real world
impacts that lead us all closer to the
Stars
so on behalf of everyone at Esa Bravo
keep creating keep innovating and keep
playing
this is
wishing everyone a wonderful Gamescom
from the International Space Station
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
looking at games for Gamescom Opening
Night Live one of the things I was most
impressed with this year is there a lot
of European Studios that want to debut
games here and also a lot of brand new
IP brand new worlds and we're going to
introduce one of those to you right now
and I think you're going to get pretty
excited about it check out this world
premiere
foreign
[Music]
has memories
[Music]
memories of all of our past
when gods
this world
but the gods vanity grew
and in their struggle we were Cast Away
stories remain
sand
in the ruins of this shattered broken
world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
s we endure
we won't let go
for now we can stand for ourselves
and face gods
[Applause]
Atlas Fallen coming in 2023
now a classic strategy game that I
remember playing in the late 90s is
Homeworld anyone else play that back in
the day
Great PC space RTS well a brand new home
world is coming out next year uh and
we've got a brand new look at some new
gameplay from Homeworld let's check it
out
[Music]
it was a simple perimeter scan
resources
but we were ambushed by colon Raiders
Fighters were no problem
it's where it's a different story
command got clever One Wing used cover
to keep himself safe on approach
[Music]
while another group found a tunnel in
the structure to sneak behind them
let's do this
it worked
just before a carrier battle group
arrived
we scrambled bombers
perfect for attacking Capital ships
we protected the resources while they
hauled in the goods which meant we could
roll out assault Rings
the Raiders weren't pushovers but
command countered their hit and run
tactics and the way their carrier
exploded
and we even grabbed a little souvenir
that missile frigid is ours now
[Music]
Homeworld 3 in the first half of 2023.
now today is a big day speaking of
Threes because it's the version 3.0
update to gentian impact which is an
incredible action RPG from hoyoverse
well today we've got an exclusive new
look at version 3.0 in the new
rainforest Nation as well as a sneak
peek of a mysterious ancient
civilization and settlement that is
found deep inside the desert let's take
a look at this world premiere
foreign
[Music]
I can't see
[Music]
I'll uproot you yeah
[Music]
Germany
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what an absolutely beautiful game and
that's not all from hoyoverse because
they also have honkai star rail in
development It's a grand Interstellar
adventure with strategic turn-based
combat and now we're going to take a new
look at the story and Adventure that
awaits you in honkai Star rail
[Music]
[Music]
of five people
three must pay a price
you are not one of them genuine
[Music]
you are one of them
foreign
the train is about to make the jump hold
on everyone
hello again it is now time for our next
Gamescom award and here are your
nominees for the Most Wanted Microsoft
Xbox game
[Music]
the dark pictures The Devil in Me
the last case of Benedict Fox
metal helsinger
and the winner is the last case of
Benedict Fox
and here to accept the award is barte
iglesiakovsky creative director at plot
twist congratulations thank you it's
quite of a shocker for us we just love
good Metro in Vania games and we are
working hard on making benefits Benedict
Fox just that and I would like to thank
Xbox team for their support and uh Rock
team for being the best publisher ever
and especially I would like to thank my
team in Krakow they are crazy talented
and my hands hold the award but their
hands make the game Tinkerbell thank you
congratulations once again the last case
of Benedict Fox and Jeff back to you
thank
you thank you very much Melly uh anyone
here a fan of Justin Roiland
Rick and Morty well he's got a brand new
game which you may have seen at Xbox's
show in June called high on life it is
coming to Xbox and Game Pass in December
and they wanted to send us just a great
gameplay clip uh you're gonna enjoy this
uh talking guns in a boss fight and
that's all I'm gonna say to set this up
I think you're gonna really this is a
trip check this out World premiere of
high on life
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we're hurting you no
[ __ ] you
are you even a real value Hunter
he's just so gross you even went in
there
yeah so stop diving into it
he's still in the place with sludge stay
in the air
you better not fall in hey I'm still
here you can still use me if you want
conflict attacks did you know that not
just all about stabbing well I'm mostly
all about stabbing and tethering but I
can also deflect attacks
I'll slice in the [ __ ] dab I'll cut
their [ __ ] heads off oh [ __ ] I'll
rip their limbs I'll [ __ ] do
everything wrong in a [ __ ] cut right
into them I'll cut their [ __ ] [ __ ]
off and eat it you know this sludge
matches your toxic personality that
wasn't even a good one
surprise flashback
hey
incoming lasers
laser just for you
hey you're just as nice and Squishy on
the inside as the rest of them let me
add a bounty hunter but well we're
having our first real boss fight
together
I'm the strongest out of all the
tournament clones
I'm impressed you made it this far my
ex-solders are extremely strong honestly
I don't think they were we're new with
this and it was pretty easy to kill them
all if I'm going out I'm taking you with
me
just stay alive I think she's basically
done for
[Music]
uh do you see that
what when
[Music]
is it
wait what are you don't eat that
dude you know she's gonna eat it
what yep no no
told you gross
you've been selected from among
thousands of candidates hey cutter to
join the lynx family you're from earth
right this is more than just a job it's
an opportunity you ever miss it
links making the worlds a better place
what they say about work and space is
true
there's something real special here
you don't have power here you never will
look around you
we're expendable
yeah
dancing between the ribs of a ship gaze
out at the rest of the human race
buzzing in the distance
that's when the sky
fills up with flames
that's the way things go
[Music]
[Music]
together
now we're talking
[Music]
about different designs
gotta help me rescue my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
bring it together now
[Music]
first announce back at the game awards
telltale's next project is based on the
Prime video series The expanse well we
showed you a little bit of the trailer
at the game awards to set up the world
now you're going to get a first Glimpse
at the gameplay with this behind the
scenes clip enjoy
[Music]
hold still we'll see what we can do
Captain drummer what are your orders
the expanse is obviously one of those
universes that has a ton of
opportunities to help great stories one
of the things I'm super excited about is
the zero g stuff that we've been doing a
big part of when we're making the game
not only are we think about the
characters we also have to think about
how can we evolve the genre in any way
or that will make players excited to be
part of this universe and feel like
they're engaging in something rather
than just being a passive audience
member he'll figure something out I know
you will
it's actually been a really interesting
thing as an actor to explore some of her
more vulnerable sides that by the time
we meet her in the series they've been
cauterized River
is the greatest score any scavenger has
ever come across
you'll need me if you want any chance of
unloading it
the craziness of exploded ship that now
constitutes several parts in a mass you
can move among and balancing that out
against almost like you're Excavating
story that's a personal story those are
people those are characters and you are
now among
they're ghosts whatever they were doing
right before they died being a scavenger
pretty dark job
excited about
play and experience the story in the
game
speaking of adapting things from Mom
medium to another here's a film
adaptation that into a game which I
don't think you would have ever expected
check this out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
goats killer clowns we got it all
tonight at Opening Night Live uh now
we've got another brand new game
announcement from a European publisher
for a Sci-Fi Action Adventure here we go
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
now we're going to talk about Gamescom
goes green which is an initiative that
has made Gamescom the first
climate-friendly gaming event in the
world the core event and this show
Opening Night Live I'm happy to say are
100 climate neutral for the first time
and that's something we all should be
very proud of
you guys are part of that too now as
part of this initiative Gamescom along
with the United Nations environmental
program initiative playing for the
planet are going to give out the first
ever Gamescom goes green award to the
best sustainability concept from an
exhibitor here at Gamescom and the
nominees are Microsoft Xbox Yuki and the
Indie Arena booth and to find out the
winner let's turn it over to Mellie
thank you thank you Jeff and yes the
winner of this year's Gamescom goes
green award is Yuki
and here to accept the award is Dr Joe
twist CEO of Yuki congratulations thank
you so much thank you Gamescom for this
wonderful award it's brilliant to be
recognized thank you to the Yuki team
who worked so hard every day to be
greener and thank you to the un's
playing for the planet Alliance for
inspiring us to change you know it's so
fantastic to see these amazing game
worlds that we're going to play in over
the next year but you know we only have
one planet to live on
and we only have one lifetime to make a
change and to protect that planet so
that we can continue to play our games
so everybody whether you're a player or
a business can make one small change
starting tomorrow and together
we can play more games together and save
the planet thank you very much thank you
Joe and congratulations once again to
Yuki and remember it is not only the
organizers or exhibitors that can go
green all of you can also make a change
by donating to the Gamescom Forest so
plan your games come free today Jeff
back to you awesome thank you very much
Melanie congratulations to Yuki uh now
it's time to announce a brand new game
from a new studio of Industry veterans
working on an ambitious new RPG here's
the first tease
foreign
Crux of reality
there exists two lies
one before the shuttle
and one behind the eye
[Music]
[Music]
lots of news here at Gamescom all right
let's talk about Xbox and Age of Empires
4 that continues to expand now we have
news on the next civilizations joining
the battle as free DLC if you want to
learn more about what's happening with
age Empires 4 tune into the Xbox Booth
stream for developer interviews on
Thursday but right now here's that
announcement from Age of Empires 4.
foreign
[Music]
must find their own path to Victory
whether you strike from afar or Ambush
up close the malians will use wit and
strategy to outmaneuver their opponents
and gain the advantage on the
battlefield
foreign
schools and the ability to Rally large
formations the Ottomans can keep the
pressure on to bring down their enemies
defenses
[Music]
when the drums of War beat how will you
emerge Victorious
history is in the making
and your place in it has just begun
[Music]
time to head to Gotham you guys excited
for Gotham Knights
well you don't have to wait long it is
coming this October and Batgirl
Nightwing Robin and red hood are going
to take over in Gotham Knights you're
probably wondering about the story who
are the villains well we've got a lot to
share in this brand new trailer and also
some exciting news the release date it's
gonna be a little earlier than you
expected
check this out
[Music]
Jim Gordon never gave up on anything
that's why Gotham City is still here
it's why I'm still here
[Music]
and I've known for a while now that
someday like him I'd have to work with
you
I've seen plenty of criminals in my
career but
nothing could have prepared me for this
[Music]
well well if it isn't brat girl
Gotham City is at her weakest
there's blood in the water
and the sharks are circling
they're all making their moves play nice
but we are
storm has risen over Gotham nothing can
stop it
see you later premiere
I need your help
your skills
your knowledge
your adaptability
foreign
you got my back
one last little surprise for you
come to watch the show Red Hood
nah I'm just here to kick your ass
pretty good trailer right October 21st
now for Gotham Knights all right now
it's time to announce a brand new game
from a new studio the global
announcement of the ambitious new
adventure game developed by Everstone
games it's called where wins meet it's
an interactive open world RPG featuring
action adventure and martial arts set in
a turbulent time in the northern Song
Dynasty the combat looks really cool
check out this announcement of where
winds meet
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
where winds meet again so much new IP
tonight it's really cool all right back
when we started o l in 2019 a very
special guest joined me here in person
uh to close the show and this year when
I told them that we were going to be
back here live in person he said well I
got to take part in some way so please
say hello to my good friend hideo Kojima
Mr Kojima
thank you Jeff
yeah game is going on
Spotify
foreign
foreign
[Music]
live we announced Park Beyond from
Olympic entertainment and Bandai Namco
and this year they've got an awesome uh
Booth experience for those of you here
in person and for those of you at home
we've got a brand new trailer that shows
you more of this incredible amusement
park simulation game
foreign
here is a little something to inspire
you be creative
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
great job guys this has a lot of
potential
couldn't we go A Step Beyond
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
what about you will you go beyond your
imagination
of Beyond coming soon
so much fun I love the diversity of
games we have here amusement parks I
love theme park back in the day great to
see that's coming out uh from Olympic
and Bandai Namco all right now it's time
to share another special announcement
here at Gamescom not a game but a
concept car that's right it's here at
Gamescom and I got to catch up with
Oliver Heimer the head of mini design
let's check it out
all right I'm over here at the mini
Booth with Oliver this is the mini
concept aceman reveal this looks so cool
I glad you like it well let's take a
look and learn more in this trailer
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh this looks so cool I have so many
questions for you all over uh first of
all I want to ask you about this
partnership a car with gaming features
and Pokemon how did this come together
yeah first of all let's talk about
Gamescom you know Gamescom is
um one of the core events of femdom pop
culture and as we ourselves are a part
of that pop culture we don't want to
miss out such a great event and the
Pokemon company International and we
have a lot in common we're both iconic
Brands and mini is more than a car it's
a character you partner to explore the
world and the world of Pokemon is full
of unique characters with special powers
so we share a love for distinctive
design and strong values
I'm going to ask you your favorite
Pokemon in a minute but first I want to
ask about the gaming features we saw a
little bit in the trailer tell us break
it down why does this appeal to gamers
so first of all it's all about the ace
men's gaming features it's designed to
be playful as the brand is the Pokemon
mode welcomes you inside of the car and
then you can connect your gaming console
to your mini and all you'll notice it's
a lot of details referencing Pikachu in
particular
the Eastman is fully electric just like
Pikachu is an electric type
so they're a perfect match
uh is there an overarching motto to this
partnership
so indeed there it is we asked ourselves
the question what is if a car could
connect it with your gaming console just
like it does with your smartphone
so we are promoting a playful mindset
just like our brand and Pokemon
so our Gamescom claim is play on never
stop playing well speaking of never stop
playing will we see you next year at
Gamescom as well yeah we plan to stay in
the game and play on for sure like we
always have from the get-go so stay
tuned awesome all right Oliver thank you
so much and we've got much more owenl
still to come
dark tide is a first person Co-op game
set in the Grim dog future of Warhammer
40 000.
welcome to tertia a sprawling Hive City
on the brink of Destruction
you are a reject a convict free to serve
the Inquisition in this darkest of ours
it is your duty to fight and if
necessary die for the emperor
you can expect no help
are you
last line of defense
foreign
[Music]
once upon a time there were two twin
sisters
Torah and Yaga
[Music]
you got it
[Music]
awesome stop it you can't hide from Baba
princess I'm how much longer you want to
be a nobody I just need to find the red
oak well you really want to find this
what the hell is wrong with this Forest
[Music]
thank you
not bad
kill it again
if anything bad happens
always head straight to the Red Oak
[Music]
[Music]
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
but don't worry there is more on
Saturday so make sure to not miss our
award show on Saturday but here are your
nominees for the Most Wanted Sony
PlayStation game
the dark pictures The Devil in Me
[Music]
lies of peace
one piece Odyssey
[Music]
and the winner is lies of pee
here to accept the award is jimon Choi
Project Director at Neil is the stage is
yours
oh thank you
um first of all I'm very proud of my
team members and uh we always do our
best to live up to the our team's name
the North and finally do you know BTS
Like BTS and Korean pop and we'll be
done off in the Korean gaming industry
thank you come time thank you congrat
Congress and once again to Liza P thank
you so much and yes that's it from me
too for tonight but before I say goodbye
I want to bring your attention to a more
serious matter the past five months of
War have been devastating for the
Ukrainian families and UNICEF and
partners on the ground are supporting
those in needs and of course funds are
needed so please consider donating at
unicef.org if it's possible and um yes
we have to take care of each other
Gamescom also supports the development
of antura the language learning game for
Ukrainian children and tour is based on
an app which was made for a Syrian War
refugees to learn the local language and
I mean in times like this it is more
important than ever to take care of each
other and I hope you keep that in mind
not only for Gamescom this week but way
after thank you so much that's it from
me and have a wonderful games come Jeff
back to you thank you you melee great to
have you with us we got a few more games
to go now one of the great things about
gamescoms we love to profile games made
in Germany and this next game was made
by four students in Berlin it was a big
success on Steam and now it's coming to
a new platform and we've got the
announcement right now
[Music]
foreign
beautiful now we're gonna get dark the
Outlast trials you guys excited for this
game the Outlast trials we showed you
last year at Gamescom open Night Live
and we haven't heard anything sensorly
from the team and everyone keeps asking
me when are we going to get to play this
well tonight we've got the world
premiere of the brand new trailer and
yes some news
on when you might get to play it here we
go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
upon identity
look at that pretty face
in harmony
[Music]
the subjugation of perception
chemical encouragement doctrine of a
person
Merry Christmas for your own good
profession
elaborate and inclusive Three Brothers
for an even greater emphasis
series of personal
rebirth enough
Political Criminals are subjected
between fatal dispensing of existence
by the promise of execution
foreign
that's right some people will get to
play something this year the Outlast
trials all right next up we've got a
tease of the first release from Embark
Studios which a lot of the veterans that
worked on the battlefield franchise in
Stockholm Sweden they've got a shooter
wrapped in a game show format where
destruction is going to play a key role
what we've got here is a short tease
with some actual gameplay in it the full
reveal is coming later in September you
can sign up starting now to get in to
start Play tests of this check out the
finals
foreign
[Applause]
we got one more game for you tonight at
Gamescom Opening Night Live and this is
one we've all been waiting
a long time for Here We Go
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
it's true Dead Island 2 coming next
February and joining me now to tell us
about this long-awaited game is Khan
Khan Great to uh to have you with us uh
first of all let's explain a little
context to that trailer we saw who is
that character that we meet
thank you Jeff it's great to be here uh
so you just met Jacob and he is just one
of our six playable characters our
zombie Slayers have Larger than Life
personalities and unique dialogue which
fits in with a very pulpy and irreverent
tone as you could tell I see the tagline
there uh see you in hell a so it looks
like we're heading to uh to Los Angeles
in this game well our pulpitone is kind
of a love letter to Classic cult
Hollywood horror B movies so where
better to set it than in Los Angeles uh
sort of a modern Paradise gone to hell
oh yeah it looks uh looks cool it's
obviously over the top uh I know you're
working on the narrative for it uh this
game has been you know long awaited for
many many years that you guys have been
working on it for a few yeah I'm sure
some fans would agree with you it has
been long awaited but uh Deep Silver Dam
Buster Studios started work on it about
four years ago we were really lucky we
got to build it from the ground up we
got to focus on what we love about the
franchise the over-the-topness and
um we think we've got a really great
action RPG out of that so let's talk
about the gameplay we saw that CG piece
obviously but what can we expect from
the gameplay when you show it so Dead
Island 2's gameplay is all about
experimenting with your preferred zombie
slaying methods just kind of going nuts
it's a combat toy box of Close Quarters
melee brutality with a few guns for fun
okay well I can't wait to learn more
when are we going to get to see more see
some gameplay of it you want to see some
gameplay I think we want to see some
gameplay you guys want to see the
gameplay
can we do it now how about now okay
let's do it here's your first look at
the gameplay of Dead Island 2. thanks
Khan
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Humanity's survival depends on the Red
Bull pumping through my veins well well
sounds like you're the star of the show
now this [ __ ]
[Music]
I will not have this Barrel in my house
[Music]
gosh this is beyond insane
[Applause]
and believe it or not there is an uncut
version that trailer you can watch
online if you want to see even more all
right well that's Dead Island two coming
in February and that is going to wrap up
all the reveals for Gamescom Opening
Night Live
2022. uh it's been a fun show but before
we go I just want to say I hope everyone
has a great Gamescom there's lots of
live streams for the next couple days
lots of things for you guys to go and
play and check out here on the show
floor and as for me and the team well
we're going to go back to Los Angeles
and get ready for the game awards 2022
which I'm excited to announce will be
live on Thursday December the 8th 2022
from the Microsoft theater in Los
Angeles we've got lots of great stuff
we're working on for that but until then
hope you guys have a great Gamescom
thanks so much for being a part of
Opening Night Live we'll see you soon
foreign